das thema wohnen und bauen ist achtung
ein wortspiel kündigt sich an eine der
großen baustellen der ampel letzte woche
war startschuss für das bündnis
bezahlbarer wohnraum unter leitung von
bauministerin klara geywitz und die
ampel ziele sind ambitioniert
400.000 neue wohnungen jedes jahr wollen
die bauen ist das überhaupt zu schaffen
auch blöd jetzt habe ich in die spannung
versaut entschuldigung wobei vornehmen
kann man sich ja alles mögliche im leben
entsprechend optimistisch sören bartol
staatssekretär im bauministerium
würden sie eine hohe wette eingehen dass
er die 400.000 schaffen in diesem jahr
ich wette grundsätzlich nicht mein ziel
ist unser ziel ist dass wir uns auf die
400.000 zu bewegen das muss irgendwann
dastehen 400.000 neue wohnungen
hunderttausend öffentlich geförderte
wohnung dafür werden wir jetzt alles tun
kämpfen und am ende werden wir ja sehen
wo wir landen ja mal sehen wo wir landen
das ergibt sich alles ne vielleicht
sollten mieter das auch so machen ich
überweise erstmal was ich kann und dann
sehen wir ja wo wir landen
es ist trotzdem gut dass es für die
mammut-aufgabe bauen endlich wieder ein
eigenes ministerium in berlin gibt 1998
wurde das abgeschafft von sehen da
lautet die traurige antwort wir
eigentlich immer der gerd warst ja
wirklich wirklich seinetwegen fängt
klara geywitz jetzt quasi von vorne an
momentan muss sich die frauen ist kein
witz beim innenministerium
kugelschreiber leyen die dann ende des
jahres zurückgegeben werden und auch in
ihrem neuen büro herrschte erst mal
verwirrung die hat bei ihrem einzug ein
großes bild im büro vorgefunden dass ihr
zunächst rätsel aufgabe am anfang habe
ich weiß nicht ganz sicher ob es eine
pinnwand ist oder kunst aber es ist in
der tat kund
[Applaus]
selbstverständlich ist das kunst was
denn sonst das bild hinter ihr heißt
alle ideen der ampel seien zu recht
unterschätze spätwerk von joseph beuys
dabei könnten dass so viele passende
sachen hängen in ihrem büro zb was weiß
ich rembrandts der mann mit dem bau helm
oder so die 400.000 wohnungen werden
immer unrealistischer und zwar wegen
fachkräfte und materialmangel sehr
logisch viele baustoffe kommen aus
russland und aus der ukraine und was man
überhaupt noch kriegt ist absurd viel
teurer als im letzten jahr es ist quasi
purer luxus
dämmplatten
denn platten kosten deutlich mehr beton
stahl ist sogar über 50 prozent teurer
um es mal einfach zu machen also die
frage holz import aus russland wird
jetzt dazu führen dass der holzpreis der
eh schon hoch ist weiter steigen dass
wir aber zum beispiel noch längere
wartelisten haben beim eichenparkett
also jetzt reicht's jetzt
reicht's
kein dach von mir aus aber ich laufe
doch nicht auf null haben
so was könnte man tun was können wir tun
endlich einen boden vorkaufsrecht für
unsere kommunen um boden spekulation
einzudämmen da reden wir seit jahren
darüber muss kommen und wir müssen
dringend überdenken was hier gebaut wird
in deutschland sehr viele neue
einfamilienhäuser immer noch da ist so
klara geywitz hat sich neulich voll in
die nesseln gesetzt und riesenärger
kriegt nur weil sie mal kurz gefragt hat
ob es nicht sinnvoller wäre mehr
bestehender einfamilienhäuser zu
renovieren statt immer neue auf den
acker zu ballern sie traut sich was die
gallwitz das deutsche einfamilienhaus
das ist schließlich weltkulturerbe die
leute lieben das ist ein in beton
gegossenes aufstiegsversprechen
man fragt sich nur warum eigentlich das
bundesbauministerium wand ein
einfamilienhaus im grünen totale idylle
nein eine dreckige lüge
den ganzen tag zieht der gestank von
verbranntem schweine aus durch die
siedlung weil irgendein und garantiert
immer grillt nervige nachbar platzen
tranchen auf dem trampolin katzen kacken
in sandkästen und überall steingarten
als sieht aus wie in pakistan
aber da wäre es wenigstens billig und
weil ihr euch schon in der bauphase
wegen jedem lichtschalter an geschrieben
habt seid die am ende sowieso geschieden
hinterließen steinen lauert das grauen
eigenheim
hat auch vorzüge wo ist denn ich muss
jeder selber wissen so die zukunft des
wohnens reden wir drüber mit unserem
experten olaf schubert der selber seit
jahren wohnt olaf schön dass du da bist
400.000 wohnungen im jahr wie können wir
das trotz material mangels noch
irgendwie schaffen
ich frage 400.000 wohnungen wozu ich
meine da bauen wir einfach ein paar
größere boden und passen mehr leute rein
dann brauchen wir das und zwölf
wohnungen ja oder sagen wir 16 für jedes
bundesland 1 aber diese material knöpfe
die wird ja immer immense ja und ich
denke wir müssen lernen zu bauen ohne
material ja meine ich es nicht das
luftschloss
sondern
indem wir vor allem den vorhandenen
wohnraum eben effektiver nutzen ja und
ich sehe zum beispiel immer wieder
brücken unter denen kaum gewohnt wird ja
oder oder eben auch bloß nachts und
sogar das macht mich traurig
nächstes problem wäre das mit dem
fachkräftemangel wie stehen wir da
dagegen frühzeitig also da muss man beim
nachwuchs wirklich eben zeitig die
weichen stellen eigentlich eigentlich
bei der zeugung also ich glaube wenn man
während des geschlechts aktes wenn man
da zum beispiel ganz fest an strom denkt
dann wird das kind bestimmt elektriker
oder
man denkt an bier dann wird's maurer
aber wir brauchen ja nicht nur mehr
handwerker sondern vor allem auch
bessere ja also ich meine manche sind ja
wirklich so grottig dann denke ich immer
dass liegt er sogar eine frau hinein
oder oder das wird eine frau besser hin
dass meint also die die handwerkerin ja
eine einem eine maurerin ja einsteigen
ein prosecco irgendwie und dann können
die vom gerüst mir hinterher pfeifen da
haben also alle was davon natürlich
wir müssten gerade in den deutschen
großstädten viel hörbar und wir müssten
verdichten trotzdem liebt der deutsche
das freistehende einfamilienhaus woher
kommt die faszination ja
ich denke die elementare bedrohung des
deutschen ist es nicht die inflation
oder putin oder bewusst die elementare
bedrohung ist der nachbar
das dummes schwein ja also ich
meine ja und wenn man die zwei ist dass
man ja den schlimmsten feind sozusagen
schon in der wohnung hat ja also die
eigene familie das hat sich so
durchgesetzt dann brauchst ja nicht noch
einen nebenan der jetzt jede woche
geklopft irgendwie kann ich mir mein ein
bogen hätte also dazu kommt natürlich
die liebe zur natur ja das gebe ich
offen zu und also ein kleiner garten und
und die maulwürfe ich meine inter stadt
triffst du ja kaum noch mit mama und
wenn dann sind es meist nur kleine hunde
ja
ich glaube die quittung kommt natürlich
dann im alter ja also irgendwann sind
die kinder ausgezogen und dann bleiben
zwei söhne ich sag mal so eine
gesichtslose also seine winzigen
schrumpft germanen in so einer riesigen
gute und buckwitz uneffektiv also hier
müsste man gegensteuern also ich mach
das so ich ziehe dann in so ein kleines
tiny house also die gibt es diese
kleinen wohn würfe habe ich mir jetzt
drei ins wohnzimmer gestellt
aber noch effektiver ist es natürlich
eigentlich ältere menschen im heim zu
betreuen ja kompakt effektiv und leider
haben ja viele angehörige skrupel ja
dann ihre älteren verwandten dort
abzugeben und hier müsste man irgendwie
gegen schauen dass man den moment der
übergabe irgendwie entbürokratisiert und
vereinfacht in meinem bett in bibis
gibt's ja auch aus der brause und
rentner klappe
klingt war olaf schubert fehlt
[Applaus]
und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe fans der feinsten unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere videos
sehen wollt
das war super tag
wir haben ich sehe auch echt clique aus
heute